اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرضون معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
كيف تقول انها تصدت لغارات روسيه هو
موسكوته
جديده في السودان والعربيه احدى
المستشفيات في الخرطوم
مصر تعلن تعطل ناقله نفط في المجرى
الملاحي لقناه السويس وتتفاعل 3 قاطرات
لسحبها
بعد تحرش في الجو والبحر
تحذر من مواجهه كارثيه
اوكرانيا مساء السبت كما اعلنت السلطه
الاوكرانيه
من جهتها على السلطات شبه جزيره القمه
لروسيا عن اسقاط تسع طائرات مسيره في
مدينه زانكوي بالقرم وقال مستشار رئيس
جمهوريه القرم الروسيه قال انه حسب
المعلومات الاولي للهجوم الاوكراني فقد تم
تسجيل اضرار لحقت بالنوافذ في عده منازل
باحدى المناطق السكنيه جراء الحادث الذي
وقع خلال الليل هذا وتميزت الحرب في
اوكرانيا مشاهدينا منذ بدايتها باستخدام
المسيرات بجميع انواعها الهجوميه وتلك
التي تستخدم في التجسس كذلك وحتى المدنيه
التي تم تحويلها لاهداف عسكريه وتريدك
مشاهدينا انتاج اعداد كبيره منها
لاستخدامها في حربها مع روسيا نتابع
حرب المسيرات هكذا يصف المراقبون الصراع
الدائره في اوكرانيا وعلى هذا الاساس وجهت
كييف قدراتها للحصول على هذا السلاح باكبر
كميه ممكنه 200 الف هذا عدد المسيرات التي
تسعى الحكومه الاوكرانيه لشرائها بحلول
نهايه العام هذا الكم الضخم سيتم انتاجه
محليا حيث ان 30 شركه محليه تنتج المسيرات
المطلوبه وقد تم توقيع عقود مبدئيه لفي
وحده لاسابيع قليله حيث تتم زياده الاعداد
المطلوبه كل فتره هناك حاجه الى المسيرات
بكل انواعها وبقدرات مختلفه من اجهزه
الاتصالات كلما زاد عدد المسيرات التي في
حوزتنا زادت قنوات الاتصال وبذلك يصبح
عملنا اكثر كفاءه
الاوكرانيون يستخدمون مسيراتهم داخل
اراضهم للدفاع ولكن كذلك للهجوم
حيث استخدموا الطائرات بدون طيار لضرب
محطه السكي لتكرير النفط في منطقه
المسيرات تسمح لقوات كييف بالحاق الضرر
بروسيا فقد وصلت الى الكرملين في هجوم لم
يلحق ضررا كبيرا بمقر الرئاسه الروسيه
ولكنه شكل ضربه قاسيه للدب الروسي امام
انظار العالم
انس النماسي العربيه
مشاهدينا معنا مراسه العربيه كاتيا صباح
الخير بدايه كيف يتفاعل ملف ارتفاع معدل
الهجمات الاوكرانيه في الداخل الروسي
نتحدث ايضا عن جزيره القرم ومناطق اخرى
ايضا في عمق روسيا
صباح الخير احمد اولا دعني ابدا من الوضع
الميداني على الحدود الحدود الروسيه تشهد
قصفا سواء كان باستخدام المسيرات او كان
باستخدام الصواريخ لا تزال تشهد خصوصا
مستمرا من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه اليوم تم
مهاجمه شبه جزيره القرم بتسع مسيرات تم
تعطيلها وطبعا اسقاطها بالنظام الدافئ
الدفاع الجوي كما تحدث رئيس شبه جزيره
القرم ايضا منطقه كورس كانت ايضا قد تعرضت
لهجوم بالمسيرات منطقه
[موسيقى]
صاروخي كما تحدثت السلطات هناك ادت طبعا
الى اضرار فقط في المساكن هناك على الحدود
بالنسبه الى ايضا هناك كان قصف سيارات ادت
الى سقوط
قتله طبعا شخصين كما تحدث تحدثت السلطات
هناك هناك نزوح كبير في منطقه الى تم
اجلاء نحو اربعه الاف مواطن روسي الى
مناطق او مراكز مخصصه لها او لا لحين يتم
طبعا السيطره على الوضع اذا الوضع طبعا
هناك استمرار في كما ذكرت في القصف وكان
هناك دعوات بالاخص قد سمعنا دعوات من قبل
قوات بعض من الاشخاص على رئيس على لسان
رئيس قوات فاكتور الذي دعا وزاره الدفاع
للسيطره على الوضع هناك في منطقه
وانما كما قال هو سيضطر الى الذهاب بنفسه
اليه السيطره على وضع في منطقه التي تشهد
منذ فتره طويله طبعا قصفا مستمرا
بالمسيرات احمد
كيف يتم التعاطي مع مساله الهجمات
الاوكرانيه بالنسبه لسكان المتقاع هل يتم
التعاطي بنفس الطريقه او بنفس السيناريو
الذي يحدث في اوكرانيا بمعنى اطلاق سفاره
الانذار ودوره
الهروب او الانتقال بسرعه الى الملاجئ ام
ان الاعتماد على الدفاعات الروسيه يعطي
سلوكا مختلفا في تعاطي مع هذه التطورات
حقيقه احمد بالنسبه الى المناطق الحدوديه
وهي تحتلف طبعا عن المناطق الاخرى الروسيه
يعني هنا في موسكو لم يكن هناك
اطلاق الاشارات او الانذار او دعوه الى
الذهاب الى الملاجئ حين تم مهاجمه العاصمه
بالمسيرات ولكن طبعا الوضع في المناطق
الحدوديه هو مختلف تماما وبالتالي هناك
رسائل يتم توجيهها عبر الهاتف المحمول الى
جميع السكان المنطقه او جميع المواطنين
المتواجدين في المنطقه التي ستتعرض الى
القصف لدعوتهم الى ذهاب او التوجه الى
مناطق امنه او الى النزول الى الملاجئ
طبعا هذا يختلف عن طبيعه القصف التي تتعرض
له المنطقه وكانت ذكرت لك هناك اربعه الف
الاف مواطن روسي تم اجلائهم من المناطق
المشتعله في اماكن سكن مؤقته لحين يتم
السيطره على المناطق على الوضع هناك احمد
شكرا لك معنا ممارسه العربيه
اهلا بك محمد وكيف تتطور الاوضاع الامنيه
في الساعه الاخيره في كييف
يعني العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف كانت تعيش
ليله صاخبه ايضا مثل يعني اسابيع الماضيه
او الايام القليله الماضيه عند الساعه
الواحده فجرا دوت سفارات الانذار كعادتها
عندما يتم اطلاق مسيرات وصواريخ بحسب
المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه تم
اسقاط اربع صواريخ وثلاثه مسيرات فقط
اطلقوا على العاصمه مدن اخرى مثل مدينه
فرانكف تعرضت لضربات بصواريخ ثلاثه مئه
وايضا تعرضت لتضارب بالمدفعيه مدفعيه
هاودر وايضا بصواريخ اس 3 مدينه مدينه
تعرضت لضربه مؤلمه حيث اصابت صواريخ اس
300 مبنى سكني من ماده الى مقتل طفل وجرح
طفلين ايضا جرح حوالي 17 اخرين كانوا في
هذا المبنى
ايضا تم اسقاط اهداف جويه
ولكن الحدث الذي يعني يتداول الان بشده في
اوكرانيا هو استهداف شبه جزيره القرم
بصواريخ بعيده المدى وايضا سيارات خاصه
منطقه جانكوي هذه المنطقه التي تقع في وسط
شبه جزيره الكرم وتضم ثلاثه في محيطها
ثلاثه مطارات عسكريه من هذه المطارات تقلع
ببعض الاحيان طائرات ومسيرات باتجاه المدن
الاوكرانيه نتالياه حدثت في مداخله
تلفزيونيه حوالي قالت ان موسم العمليات
الاوكرانيه الصيفي قد بدا وهذا ايزانا
بمقاله ايضا الرئيس في مقابله يعني امس
قال ان يعني موعد الهجوم المضاد قدحان
ويعني ان العمليات التي تقوم بها القوات
الاوكرانيه الان بضرب نقاط وبعيده المدى
مخازن اسلحه مدينه بريديانس لوغانست هي
قصف بشكل يومي ينقلون ما يحدث في الدمباس
في باخم في محيط باخموت ولو بشكل مختلف
الى داخل الاراضي الروسيه له تاثير كبير
هناك رعيان عام في اوكرانيا الراي العام
الاول متخوف من رده الفعل الراي الثاني
يقول انه يجب ان تفعل اوكرانيا كل ما
تستطيع لتغيير قواعد اللعبه التي بدات
تتغير شيئا فشيئا مثلا يعني قبل او قبل
حوالي سنه من الان كان من الخطوط الحمر
استهداف اهداف او قيام اوكرانيا بعمليات
داخل الحدود الروسيه الان بدات تنقلب
الايه بدات الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه تعمل
ويعني القطع الاوكرانيه بدات تهاجم العنقر
شكرا لك من كيف كنت معنا الصحفيين محمد
البابا تحياتي محمد
يواصل قائد مجموعه العسكريه الروسيه
الخاصه في جيني بيجو الايداع بتصريحات
واتهامات جديده لكن هذه المره تطال اروقه
الكريم
القى بها قائد فاجنر متحدثا هذه المره عن
العاب خطيره تمارسها جهات داخل اروقه
الكرملين لتدمير الدوله الروسيه وبث
الفتنه فيها
حذر وهدد من انه في حال دب الصراع بين
فاجنر والقوات الشيشانيه فان الرابح محسوم
لكن سينتج عنه حمام دم كما قال
صدقني لو حصلت مواجهه بين قوه فاكنار
وقوات اخماط الشيشانيه سيكون النصر لنا
لكن سيؤدي ذلك الى اراقه الكثير من الدماء
فصائل مجهوله من داخل
صندوق بندوره لزرع الانقسامات على حد وصفه
ليؤكد من جديد على ان الخلاف القديم مع
المقاتلين الشيشان قد تم تسويته بالفعل
الخلاف بيننا وبين المقاتلين الشيشان قد
تم تسويته لكن الاقتتال الداخلي في
الكريملين فتح صندوق بندوره من الانقسامات
عاصفه من الاتهامات اللاذعه شانها قائد
فاجنر على وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ايضا بعد
ان تعرضت منطقه بيلجرود في الايام الاخيره
لقصف وهجمات مكثفه
اذا لم توقف وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ما يحدث
في منطقه بيل جرود حيث يتم الاستيلاء على
اراضي روسيه فمن الواضح اننا سنتدخل ولن
ننتظر دعوه او اذنا للانتشار في المنطقه
اثار الشد والجذب المستمران بين قائد قوه
فاغنر والنخب الروسيه تساؤلات عده بشان
طبيعه العلاقه بين الكرملين والمجموعه
العسكريه الخاصه
وسط ضبابيه العلاقه بين الجانبين
افاد التقارير الصحفي ان مجموعه مواليه
لاوكرانيا تستخدم اسلحه غربيه في هجمه ضد
روسيا كشف مسرور امريكيون مشاهدينا لصحيفه
واشنطن روسا المتحالفين مع كييف ضد موسكو
استخدموا ما لا يقل عن اربع مركبات
تكتيكيه منحتها في الاصل الولايات المتحده
وبولندا لاوكرانيا حيث ان هذا الامر اثار
تساؤلات حول مدى قدرتكييف على ضبط الاسلحه
الممنوحه لها من قبل الغرب وتنظيم عمليه
استخدامها من قبل الموالين لها ووفقا
للصحيفه مشاهدينا فقط شوهدت هذه الاسلحه
بحوزه مجموعه روسيه مواليه لاوكرانيا شنت
هجمات على منطقه بالغورود الروسيه
الى السودان مشاهدينا حيث دعت السعوديه
والولايات المتحده الجيش السودانيه وقوات
الدعم الاتفاق على وقف اطلاق نار جديد
وتنفيذه بشكل فعال بهدف وقف دائم للعمليات
العسكريه وذكرت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
في بيان ان الرياض واشنطن حريستان على
استمرار المحادثات مع وفتي الجيش وقوه
الدعم السريع واضافت ان المحادثات تركزت
على سبل تسهيل المساعدات الانسانيه
والتواصل الى اتفاق بشان خطوات ينبغي على
الطرفين اتخاذها على المدى القريب قبل
الاستئناف محادثات جده واشار البيان الى
ان وفدي الجيش والدعم السريع موجودان في
مدينه جده رغم تعليق المحادثات وانتهاء
وقف اطلاق النار ميدانيا افاد مراسل
العربيه بتواصل اشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في عده مناطق
في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم مع تركيزها
في شمالي مدينه الخرطوم بحري وتتزامن تلك
الاشتباكات مع قصف جوي ينفذه سلاح
الجو السوداني على المدينه مصحوبا بقصف
مدفعي من قاعده كرري ونقل المراسل عن
مواطني جنوب مدينه ام درمان سماعهم لاصوات
اطلاق نار ودوي اسلحه خفيفه ومتوسطه مع
تحليق الاطعام استطلاع والمروحيات في سماء
المدينه التي تشهد انقطاعا للتيار
الكهربائي في عد من احيائها مشاهدينا
اما في دار خور فقد افادت مصادر العربيه
بان اشتباكات دارت السبت بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع الشمالي المدينه
ادت لمقتل خمسه وعشرين شخصا بشكل موازي
افادت مصادر سودانيه بوفاه شخصين الى
ثلاثه يوميا في مدينه الجنينه غربوي
الاعتذار بسبب انهيار القطاع الصحي
والاوضاع الانسانيه الصعبه وكشفت مصادر عن
وجود عدد من القناصات في المدينه وسط
انباء عنيه جماعات مسلحه السيطره على
مدينه الجنينه
[موسيقى]
منذ اندلاع الصراع في السودان انتشرت
عمليات نهب وسرقه على نطاق واسع شملت
الاسواق التجاريه وامتدت حتى للمقر
الحكوميه والوزارات ما وضع المواطن
السوداني امام مواقع صعب في ظل تبادل
الاتهامات بين طرفي الصراع
لاستثناء سواء في ام درمان او في ولايات
ومدن السودان الاخرى عمليات سرقه ونهب لم
تفرق بين محل تجاريه او مقر حكوميه
هنا في سوق ام درمان الرئيسي يعيش التجار
ورواد السوق حاله من الهلع والالم بعد
انتشار عمليات النهب التي طالت غالبيه
المتاجر في حين تعرضت اخرى لحرق كامل
بعد
ساعه
دي كلها زي ما بيقولوا الضفه دي من اولها
لاخر هذه اولا فتيل الهندي واقع مر حل
بغالبيه المدن السودانيه فمنذ بدء
الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم السريع منتصف
ابريل الماضي لم تتوقف عمليات السرقه وسط
اتهامات متبادله بين طرفي الصراع وعجز
الشرطه عن تامين الاسواق والمراكز
الحكوميه بل وحتى المنازل
عمليات النهب والتخريب هذه القت بظلالها
ايضا على مؤسسات الدوله بما فيها الخدميه
والصحيه اذ شهدت وزاره الغربيه والتعليم
بجنوب دارفور عمليات تخريب شملت حرقا
كاملا لمخازن الوزاره ومطابع الامتحانات
الوحيده التي تقدم الخدمات ايضا لولايتي
شرق ووسط دارفور المؤسف ايضا تم حرق كل
المطابع باعتنا التي نطبع بها الامتحانات
التي نضع بها الامتحانات للمراحل المختلفه
وبنضع بها ايضا لاخواننا في وسط دارفور
ونضع بها لاخواننا في شرق دارفور حادثه من
بين مجموعه حلت بالسودانيين كانت وراء
تعليق ولايه جنوب دارفور العام الدراسي
واغلاق المدارس الاجل غير مسمى وهو من عكس
على حياه السودانيين فلا خدمات سواء صحيه
او تعليميه فيما يعجز التجار عن تقدير حتى
خسائرهم الفادحه نتيجه النهب ويبقى
المواطن السوداني اسيرا لكل هذه الازمات
ومن اقليم مشاهدينا معنا الصحفي صالحه
وعلامه اهلا بك صالح دعنا نبدا من اقليم
دافو حيث تتواجد اين تتركز عمليات النهب
والسلب في هذا الاقليم وهل من حلول بدات
تروح في الافق ربما
نعم عمليات النهب والسلبيه طالت يعني جميع
مدن اقليم دارفور وايضا هنالك عمليات نهب
وسلفي الطرق المؤديه الى المدن التي تربط
ولايات دارفور الخمس اكثر الولايات التي
تعرضت لعمليات نهب وسلب وتدمير كامل هي
ولايه وسط دارفور وولايه غرب دارفور
انعدمت ملامح يعني الدوله تماما في
الولايتين هنالك يعني عمليات تدمير طالت
جميع المنشات حتى المنشات الصحيه والاسواق
العامه وحتى ايضا مراكز الشرطه لم يتبقى
الا قياده الجيش والدعم السريع لم تطالها
عمليات التدمير وعمليات النهب والسلفي وسط
دارفور وايضا في غرب ادار فو يعني الوضع
في غرب دارفور هو وضع ماساوي هنالك اكثر
من 100 الف لاجئ ادري الشاديه في الحدود
التجاديه هنالك عمليه نزوح كبيره داخل
الاردن ما زال المواطنين لما يغارب الشهر
هم يعني داخل الاحياء في الطرقات في
الساحات العامه في المدارس بلا ماوى وبلا
علاج وبلا غذاء انقطاع في الاتصالات حتى
الان العالم لا يعلم شيئا وسط دارفور
وايضا عن غرب دارفور هنالك وفيات يوميه لا
حصر لها بسبب انعدام الاكسجين بسبب ايضا
انعدام الدواء وانعدام المراكز الصحيه
ايضا مدينه نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب دارفور
لم تسلم من عمليات النهب والسلب حتى
البارحه هنالك عمليات نهب للبنوك المصارف
التجاريه بنياله هنالك اموال كثيره تم
نهبها من مدينه نيالا هنالك ايضا سيارات
ما يتم في الخرطوم هو يتم ايضا في في
عواصم دارفور وفي مدن دارفور عمليه النهب
التي تطال المنازل هنا ايضا
العمليات عمليات انها يعني هل نتحدث عن
عصابات بعينها نتحدث عن جماعات مس لحه
هنتحدث عنه كما يقول الجيش السوداني ان
هذه العمليات تقوم به عمليات تقوم بها
قوات الدعم السريع امم اين تكمن حقيقه ما
يجري هناك يعني
الجميع يعلم بان اقليم دارفور هو اقليم هش
يعني عمليات التفلت والنهب كانت في السابق
موجوده ولكن تم احتواء هذه العمليات
بالانتشار الكبير للقوات الفتره الماضيه
كان هنالك قوات تشكل من شتى الوحدات
بالقوات المسلحه والشرطه والجيش والدعم
السريع تعمل على محاربه هذه الظواهر لكن
ما ان ينفرط الامن عادت يعني هذه الظاهره
بشكل كبير جدا يعني من ينهبون لا ينتمون
ابدا لاي جهه بحسب يعني عدد من البيانات
التي صدرت الدعم السريع ذكر مرارا وتكرارا
بان بانه هو ليست جزء من هذه العمليات لكن
هنالك اتهامات للدعم السريع في غرب دارفور
بالتدخل في مدن عديده ايضا بالتدخل لكن هو
ينفي هذا مرارا وتكرارا يعني عمليات النهب
وسلب تتم من مجموعات اعتادت عليه على
النهب والسلب يعت على العبث بالاسواق
والاماكن العامه هذه المجموعات تمتلك سلاح
وتمتلك ايضا سيارات
هنالك انتشار كبير جدا لسلاح في هذه
الفتره ظهور للسلاح في الطرقات ظهور
للسلاح فيها الاسواق ظهور ايضا السلاح في
عدد من مدن دارفور بشكل كبير جدا وبشكل
مكثف كله يصب في
نعم صالح
طيب يبدو انفقنا الاتصال مع الصحفي صالح
ابو علامه كنت مع لم يقيم دارفور شكرا
جزيلا لك صالح
ومع دخول الحرب في السودان يومها الخمسين
عدد قليل من المستشفيات في شرق العاصمه
الخرطوم ظلت تعمل رغم انها تقع في دائره
الاشتباك العسكري بين الجيش والدعم السريع
مستشفى دريم التخصصي مشاهدينا للولاده هو
الوحيد الذي يعمل رغم شحن امكانيات ويعاني
من عده نواقص هامه ووضعا امنيا مضطربا
ايضا يؤثر على تقديم الخدمه نتابع
الطفل عمر ولد قبل ساعه واحده جاء الى
الدنيا في ظروف بالغه التعقيد اثرى الحرب
التي تدور روحاها قرب المشفى الذي يقع شرق
الخرطوم رغم ذلك فقد وهب املا كبيرا
لاسرته بقدومه واملا اخر للاطباء الذين
حضروا في ذات المكان وفات اطفال قبل ولاده
عمر نقص الاكسجين جعل هذه الحضانه
الطبيعيه في مستشفى دريما التخصصي لا
تستطيع ان تستقبل عدد من الحالات التي يتم
ولادتها هنا في المستشفى او تاتي من
الخارج الحاجه اللي بتقطع القلب انه يعني
المستشفى ده استقبل حاله طفل ناقص مشط
مستشفى التركي مشي مستشفى المنوره لما
يفعج
ولدت لكن البيبي كان خلاص الطفل كان ناقص
تتجهز سناء الطيب لدخول غرفه العمليات فقد
استطاعت الوصول للمستشفى في الوقت المحدد
لها رغم التوترات الامنيه والله الشارع في
توتر لكن يعني الحمد لله ما واجهتنا صعوبه
يعني في انه نصل للمستشفى وكده حاليا يعني
يحددوا لي عمليه وان شاء الله بعد ساعه او
ساعتين
ان شاء الله رب العالمين
استمرار الحرب التي صعبت وصول الامداد
الدوائي وانقطاع الكهرباء لساعات وايام
طويله يهدد باستمرار التقديم الخدمات
الصحيه بصوره مقبوله المستشفى 18 يوم
وكانت كهرباء تقاطعه طوال يعني 18 يوم كنا
بنضطر ان احنا بنوفر الجهاز
زي ما بيقولوا بالسوق الاسود يعني
بالمستشفى مختص واحد فقط يعمل دون انقطاع
منذ قرابه الشهر ويناشد بضروره توفير بعض
المساعدات حتى لا تتوقف الخدمه تمينا ما
يقاربين يوم شغالين المستشفى ما يقبل
مشكله الاكسجين الفتره الاخيره يعني عندنا
عدد اسطوانات بسيطه لكن دايرين يعني
محتاجين يعني لان احنا شغالين عليه عمليات
نحتاج كميه بتاع الدم
يبدو الوضع متازيما جدا وصعبا لعده نواقص
اساسيه بسبب الحرب فهذه الاسطوانات فارغه
ولا تستطيع ان تهب الصغار الخدجه جرعه
الحياه في زمن الحرب عمار بوشيبا العربيه
الخرطوم
افاد مراس العربي ان ثماني سفن متوقفه في
قناه السويس ناقله النفط المتعطله هو
اعلنت هيئه قناه السويس المصريه دفع ثلاث
قاطرات لسحب ناقله نفط تعطلت محركاتها في
المجرى الملاحي وقال رئيس الحي اسامه ربيع
ان حركه قافله الشمال ستعود الى طبيعتها
عقب سحب ناقله النفط التي كانت في طريقها
من روسيا الى الصين ومن القاهره
الى اي مرحله اذا وصلت عمليه
سحب الناقله ناقله النفط من مجره قناه
السويس
صباح الخير يا احمد الناقله الان يتم
سحبها طبقا للصور التي رايناها صور تتبع
السفن لانها كانت في واحده من قطاعات
القناه الشماليه التي ليس بها ازدواج ويتم
سحبها لمنطقه من الممكن ان تتوقف فيها
للاصلاح لكي تستانف مره اخرى حركه العبور
رئيس هيئه قناه السويس منذ اقل من ساعه
كان قد تحدث الى احد البرامج التلفزيونيه
المحليه وذكر فيها انه في تقديره ان هناك
يعني ساعه من العمل
تستانف بعدها الحركه فنحن ربما ننتظر في
ايه لحظه ان يصلنا ان يصل لنا هذا الخبر
الصور اظهرت تحرك السفينه من موقع الى
موقع
ويبدو ان من الصور اذا كنت قد قراتها بشكل
صحيح انه يتم الان صفها او ايقافها في
منطقه يسمح فيها بالاصلاح دون ان يكون
هناك اي تعكير حركه الملاحه في القناه
القافله قافله الشمال المتجهه جنوبا كانت
تضم تسعه عشر سفينه ترتيب
محل الخبر كان ترتيبها الحادي عشر
والحاديه عشر كناقله نفط
وتوقفت الحركه من بعدها لثماني سفن اخرى
منها نقلتان
للنفطس ليست من السفن القديمه هي سفينه
تعتبر حديثه بنيت عام 2016 هذا يعني قصير
في عمر السفن بطبيعه الحال كما نعلم
السفينه ترفع علم مالطا طولها 275 متر
تقريبا وعرضها يكاد يقترب من الخمسين متر
حاليا عمليه الرباط كما يطلق عليها اهل
الملاحه في قناه السويس يعتمد على ايصال
كابلات من القطرات لكي يتم سحب السفينه
المتعطله هذا حدث يعني او هذه الحادثه
حدثت من قبل وتحدث مساله تعطل السفن خلال
العبور وهناك نوع من البروتوكول تتعامل
بهيئه قناه السويس اساسه بطبيعه الحال
وجود مرشد لكل تابع لهيئه قناه السويس
يعتلي ظهر السفينه قبل الابحار في المجرى
الملاحيه واصحاب السفينه حتى نهايه المجرى
الملاحيه وخروجها سواء من جهه الجنوب او
جهه الشمال وبالتالي اسلوب الابلاغ عن
الاعطال المتطور جدا وايضا يتم التعامل
معه على الفور من المتوقع ان يكون هذا
التعطل مؤقت بصوره كبيره وكذلك بالنسبه
لقافله الجنوب سيتم ايقافها قليلا في
منطقه البحيرات هي تتجه من السويس شمال
سيتم الانتهاء من هذه الحادثه او يتم دفع
السفينه الى خارج المجال من حيث المتابعه
دائمه شكرا لك من القاهره على كل هذه
المعلومات وتفاصيل كنت معنا تامر نصرت
مراسله العربيه
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
للمره الاولى منذ خمس سنوات لقاءات
ايرانيه امريكيه مباشره ركزت على تبادل
السجناء وتحسين البيئه لاي محادثات نوويه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد للمره الاولى
منذ خمس سنوات لقاءات ايرانيه امريكيه
مباشره حيث اشار صحيفه
حول كيفيه التعامل مع برنامج نووي
الايراني خوفا من نشوب حرب اقليميه المزيد
في هذا التقرير
جهه التوسع النووي الايراني في ظل تعطل
التفاهمات حول الملف النووي موضوع نقاش
عاد الى طاوله الدول الغربيه صحيفه
اشارت الى التواصل الامريكي ايراني مباشر
الحديث الرئيسي فيه ملف التبادل الاسرى
لكنه قد يؤدي لفتح المحادثات النوويه
مجدده مؤشرات تقول الصحيفه انها جاءت عبر
اتصالات عده بين المسؤولين الغربيين
ونظرائهم الايرانيين خلال الاشهر الاخيره
بدءا باجتماع اوسلو مارس الماضي بين
مسؤولين فرنسيين والمان وبريطانيين مع علي
باقر المفاوض النووي الايراني
ثم لقاءات عده جمعت بين مبعوث الولايات
المتحده الى ايران والسفير طهران لدى
الامم المتحده
الصحيفه اشارت الى ان الغرب يتحرك
بالتوازي مع تزايد المخاوف من توسع
الانشطه النوويه لايران ما قد يؤدي الى
نشوب حرب اقليميه حيث قامت طيران بتخصيب
اليورينيوم الى مستويات ستمكنها من انتاج
مواد كافيه لتصنيع سلاح النووي في اقل من
اسبوعين حسب تصريحات مسؤولين امريكيين
فيما اكد التقديرات الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه تضاعف مخزون ايران من
اليورينيوم المخصب لقرابه 23 مره بارتفاع
يقدر بنحو طن وبنسبه تفوق
25% منذ فبراير الماضي
يشكل ضعف الحد المنصوص عليه في اتفاق 2015
التاريخي بين طهران والقوه الدوليه عوده
دول الغربيه للتفكير بالتفاوض مع ايران
رغم توقفه منذ سبتمبر العام الماضي رده
دبلوماسيون غربيون الى الحاجه لخطه
دبلوماسيه لكبح مخططات طيران النوويه
ناددت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه بالتصرفات
التي وصفتها بالخطره للجيش الصيني في اسيا
وذلك بعد حادثتين وقعتها بين قوات البلدين
في الايام الاخيره في مضيق تايوان وبحر
الصين الجنوبي وقال المتحدث باسم
قمه شامبيلا الامنيه في سنغافوره لا تزال
تشعر بقلق ايزاء الانشطه الخطيره
والاكراهيه بشكل متزايد لبكين في المنطقه
من هذه المشاهدين حذر وزير الدفاع الصيني
لشانكو امام قمه حوار الامنيه في سنغافوره
حذر من اقامه تحالفات عسكريه شبيهه بحلف
شمال الاطلسي في منطقه اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ قائلا انها ستغرق المنطقه في دوامه
من الصراع كما اعتبر المسؤول العسكري
الصيني ان المواجهه بين بلاده وامريكا
ستكون كارثيه لا يمكن للعالم ان يتحملها
نقلت عن وزير الدفاع الصيني قوله ان كل
محاولات التدخل الاجنبي في تايوان ستنتهي
بالفشل
مشاهدينا معنا من بكين الصحفي نادي الرانج
ومن واشنطن الباحث في الشؤون الامريكيه
والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس اهلا بكما
سيد نادر وسيد ايهاب وابدا معك سيد نادي
الرانج هذه المناوشات العلنيه والحرب
الكلاميه بين المسؤولين الامريكيين
والصينيين في هذا التوقيت ما الذي تكشفه
عن مستوى العلاقات التي او الذي وصلت اليه
العلاقه بين البلدين
اهلا ومرحبا بكم هذا هذا في المرحله حاليا
العلاقات هناك تدهور للعلاقات السينيه
الامريكيه بسبب
الاستفزازات المستمره من قبل الولايات
المتحده
للمصالح الجوهريه لسين في مساله
وكذلك
تمام نعم طيب تفضل البقاء معي سيد نادر
وسيد ايهاب ساعود اليكما من جديد لكن
اسمحوا الان بالانتقال مع مشاهدينا الى
بغداد ونتابع هذا المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير
الخارجيه العراقي فؤاد حسين ونظيرها
السوري فيصل المقداد
اخي وزميلي
السيد فيصل المقداد
وزير الخارجيه
والمغتربين في سوريا واهلا ومرحبا بكم في
بلدكم العراق وايضا بالوفد المرافق لمعالي
الوزير
العلاقات السوريه
العراقيه التاريخيه علاقات مشترك في
الواقع لا نتحدث عن
علاقات بين
البلدين حينما نتحدث عن العلاقات بين
الشعبين هي علاقات عميقه ومشتركه
والموقف العراقي بالنسبه لوضع السوري
موقف واضح كان دوما
نسعى
ونتحدث ونطرح
مواقفنا في
سواء الجامعه العربيه اجتماعات المجلس
الوزاري للجامعه العربيه او
في الاجتماعات الاخرى في اوروبا او في
واشنطن ونيويورك
كنا نتحدث ومن منطلق مبدئي عن معاناه
الشعب السوري
كنا نتحدث هو من منطلق مبدئي عن اللاجئين
السوريين كنا نتحدث ومن منطلق مبدئي عن
النازحين السوريين
كنا نتحدث ايضا ومن منطلق لها علاقه
بالوضع العراقي
بالوضع الامني في سوريا
الوضع الامني في سوريا
يؤثر مباشره
على الوضع الامني في العراق والعكس صحيح
اذا موقف الحكومه العراقيه والحكومات
المتعاقبه منذ
2005 لحد الان هو دعم
الشعب السوري
والعمل
لمساعده الشعب السوري
نحن كنا من المبادرين
في
اجتماعات
الجامعه العربيه
وطلب عوده سوريا الى مقعدها
ونحن السعداء ان سوريا عادت الى مقعدها في
الجامعه العربيه
وكان لدينا اجتماعات في عمان
الوزراء الاربعه وزراء خارجيه مصر العربيه
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه والمملكه
الاردنيه الهاشميه والعراق
مع زميلنا
الاخ الوزير العزيز فيصل مقداد
وتواصلنا الى اعلان
عمان
واعلان عمان سيكون لنا
خطه للعمل المستقبلي في هذا طبعا وظيفه
ايضا
زميلنا ووزير خارجيه لبنان الى الفريق
الرواعي
وسوف يكون لدينا مباحثات
مباحثات مستمره في
الاطار الخماسي طبعا
مباحثات مستمره مع وزير خارجيه سوريا في
هذا المجال
لكيفيه تعامل مع الوضع الانساني في سوريا
الوضع الانساني في سوريا وضع صعب جدا
ونحتاج الى تحرك تحرك على المستوى
الاقليمي
طبعا مستوى ثنائي لكن ايضا اقليمي ودولي
قضيه اللاجئين السوريين ايضا جزء مهم من
هذه المساله او هذه المشكله كيفيه التعامل
مع اللاجئين السوريين
وخاصه اللاجئين موجودين في الدول المحيطه
في لبنان في الاردن وفي العراق من
المعلومه في العراق نحن استقبلنا حوالي
250 الف لاجئ
واكثر هؤلاء موجودين في المخيمات في
كردستان العراق
فاذا التحرك في
المرحله القادمه
سيكون حول المساله الانسانيه ومساعدات
الانسانيه وكيفيه ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى داخل سوريا
القضيه السياسيه ايضا جزء من تتعلق بان
تحرك هذه المجموعه
وهناك اجتماعات مختلفه
وفي اطر مختلفه في الواقع حول
المساله السوريه ولكن
الدول المحيطه بسوريا لم تكن متواجده خاصا
دول
العراق والاردن ولبنان ومصر
اذن سوف نحاول ان نكون ضمن هذه الاطر لكي
نطرح المساله من جوانم اخرى
ونطرح القضايا
من وجهه نظر اخرى تتعلق بالشعب السوري
ومساعده الشعب السوري
تبعتنا في
هذا اليوم ايضا قضيه كيفيه العمل المشترك
بين العراق وسوريا
لمحاربه تجاره
وحركه المخدرات
من المعلوم ان
العراق
ممر
لهذه الحركه ولكن ايضا
ومع الاسف انه بدا ايضا استهلاك المخدرات
في المجتمع العراقي اذا من المهمه العمل
مع دول المحيطه
للعراق
عمل المشترك لمحاربه هذه الظاهره الخطيره
على المجتمع العراقي ولكن ايضا على
المجتمع السوري
تطرقنا الى بعض القضايا
التي تتعلق
ونطرح وجهه نظر
الوزراء
او تشكيله
والتي
تمت الموافقه عليها من قبل الجامعه
العربيه
سوف نشارك في هذا المؤتمر في بروكسل ونلقي
النظر على الوضع المزري
والقاسي
والصعب للمجتمع السوري
وكيفيه
محاوله سوريا
مره اخرى
ارحب بزميلي
الاخ فيصل المقداد في بغداد واهلا ومرحبا
بين اخوانه
لمعالي الوزير برنامج مكثف سوف يلتقي
بفخامه
رئيس الجمهوريه
ودوله رئيس الوزراء
وسياده القاضي رئيس المجلس القضاء
بالاضافه الى
رئيس مجلس النواب اهلا ومرحبا بكم
شكرا معالي الوزير على كل ما قلتموه
انا في بلدي
اشعر بالاعتزاز لزياره بغداد
عمق التاريخ
رمز الحضاره
موقع
لشعوبنا العربيه
لم يهتز
وبقي صامدا في وجه كل
محاولات النيل من موقعه ومن مواقفه
عندما نزور بغداد
فاننا في فجر التاريخ
وعمق الحضاره العربيه
وهذا
يعطينا دائما الالهام
لكي نبذل كل الجهد من اجل ان
نستمر بتعزيز اواصر العمل
السؤال المطروح دائما هل هذا سهل
انا اقول ان ذلك صعب
وكان اقرب الى المستحيل في بعض الاحيان
لكن عندما تتوحد ايرادات شعبينا في سوريا
وفي العراق
ويكون هنالك تواصل دائم بين قيادتي
البلدين
فاننا نضع حدا لهذا المستحيل
وها هو العراق
الذي رايناه قبل عده ايام
بعد الزلزال الذي اصاب سوريا
يهرع بكل ابنائه
بغض النظر عن ولائهم وبغض النظر عن طيفهم
بغض النظر عن مكانهم وجغرافيتهم
يرعون لكي يؤدوا ما شعروا
هذا المؤتمر الصحفي من بغداد لوزير
الخارجي العراقي فؤاد حسين ونظيره السوري
فيصل المقداد
اعود مره اخرى مشاهدينا الى ضيفي من بكين
الصحفيين جيرانغو ومن واشنطن ايضا الباحث
في الشونه الامريكيه والعلاقات الدوليه
ايهاب عباس اهلا بكم من جديد سيد نادر
وسيد ايهاب واعتذر منكم الانتظار استاذ
ايهاب قبل قليل او قبل الانتقال لهذا
المؤتمر الصحفي السيد نادر كان يتحدث عن
ان الاستفزازات الامريكيه هي السبب في
تدهور العقاد بين واشنطن وبكين ما رايك في
هذا الطرح وهتتحمل واشنطن المسؤوليه
الاكبر حول هذا المستوى من العلاقات
نعم اهلا بحضرتك واهلا بالضيف الكريم وبكل
المشاهدين يعني انا اتفق مع الضيف ان ربما
هذه الاستفزازات
الامريكيه هي التي يعني تشعل
فتيل ازمه ربما مع الصين في وقت قريب خاصه
وان الولايات المتحده هي التي موجوده
بالقرب من الحدود الصينيه ومن تايوان
والبحر الصيني الجنوبي وليس العكس واذا ما
افترضنا ان العكس يحدث فالولايات المتحده
ايضا لن تسكت يعني اذا كان للصين قوات
وتحاول ان تقوم باي عمليات استفزازيه في
مياه اقليميه قريبه من الولايات المتحده
سيكون هذا الموقف للولايات المتحده عندها
موقفا حازما من الصين وحاسما بكل تاكيد
لكن في التوقيت نفسه الولايات المتحده
لديها حلفاء كثر حول الصين وترغب ويرغبون
في ان يكون هناك دفاع مشترك بينهم ودعم
مشترك
القوات خاصه ان هناك دائما يعني مخاوف من
ان تتوغل الصين في بحر الصين الجنوبي
وتفرض سيطرتها وهيمنتها على هذه الاماكن
بخلاف الدول الموجوده هناك وخاصه ان الملف
التايواني ايضا هو ملف ازمه مشتعل بالرغم
من ان امريكا يعني نعلم انها توقعت على
الاتفاقيات والمعاهدات الدوليه التي تقول
ان تايوان جزء من الاراضي الصينيه الا ان
لها علاقات قويه مع تايوان كجزيره ولا
تعترف بها صحيح طيب
من مساله التحالف الذي ترغب واشنطن فيه
تشكيله من دول المنطقه في اسيا وفي المحيط
الهادئ بحسب ما يفهم الكلام ايهاب ان
استفزازات الصين ايضا تلعب دورا في توحيد
هذه الدول وفي دفعها نحو هذا التحالف مع
واشنطن ما رايك
اهلا ومرحبا بكم في الحقيقه ليس
اعمال الصين الذي دفع هذا هو
نظريه التحديدات الصينيه التي تروجها
الولايات المتحده لهذه الدول وتخريف هذه
الدول وصنع يعني
الاعداء الوهميين او
لها وهذا كلها جعل يعني هذه الدول يعني
تخاف من الصين
هي عدو وهميه لهذه الدول
طبعا لا الصين لم ترسل
الطائراتها الحربيه وسفنها حربيه الى اي
مكان قربي باي دوله عكس الولايات المتحده
ما تريد ان تحافظ فقط الدفاع عن سيادتها
ووحدتها اعراضها وتريد ان يعني تساهم في
السلام والاستقرار في هذه المنطقه دائما
تتماسك
بالتنميه السلميه وكذلك هناك
التنميه الصينيه والتطور الصين ايضا هي
تعتبر فرصه للدول المجاوره لها فهناك
مساهمات الكبيره الصينيه للنمو الاقتصادي
العالمي لنمو الاقتصادي في هذا المنطقه
فكل الدول في الحقيقه مستفيده من التطور
الصين وحده هو الواقع ولكن هذا الواقع
يعني هو يمكن ان يشكل تحديد لحيوانات
الامريكيه في هذه المنطقه فل
الولايات المتحده صنع الاعداد الوهميين
وتقوم بتقريف الدول المجاوره للصين ولكي
تشكيله سياسيه وعسكريه ضد
وكل هذا حدث هو من اجل البقاء
حفاظ على حيواناتها في هذه المنطقه من
خلال
الامريكيه والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس
تحياتي لكما
مشاهدينا قالت مصادرز ان مسؤولين من نحو
20 من اجهزه المخابرات الكبرى في العالم
عقد اجتماع سريا على اهم اجتماعات حوار
شامبيلا الامني في سنغافوره واضافت
المصادر ان هذه الاجتماعات تنظمها حكومه
سنغافوره وتعقد سرا في مكان منفصل الى
جانب القمه الامنيه منذ سنوات عده كما
اكدت مصادر لرؤيه المشاهدين ان مديره
المخابرات الوطنيه الامريكيه في الاجتماع
السري ممثله للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
في حين كانت الصين من بين الدول الاخرى
الحاضره معتبرين ان الاجتماع عنصر مهم على
اجنده الظل الدوليه وانه يعد وسيله لتعزيز
فهم النوايا ومواطن الامور على نحو اعمق
على حد وصفهم
عاد ثلاثه رواد فضاء صينيين بسلام الى
الارض بعدما ان يزوم مهمه بل مهمه فضائيه
في محيط الفضاء الصينيه في محطه الفضاء
الصيني عفوا وصفت بالناجحه وهبطت الكبسوله
النحاسيه للمركبه الفضائيه 15 في منطقه
منغوليا بشمال البلاد وكان رواد الفضاء
الثلاثه امضوا سته اشهر في محطه الفضاء
وانجزوا مهمات من بينها المشيو في الفضاء
وتجارب مختلفه
قبل نهايتها الاخباريه مشاهدينا نذكر
بابرز العناوين
[موسيقى]
كيف تقول انها تصدت لغارات روسيه
لهدنه جديده في السودان والعربيه ترصد
معاناه احدى المستشفيات بالخرطوم
مصر تعلن نجاحها عمليه التحريك ناقله نفط
عالقه في قناه السويس وانتظام حركه
الملاحه
بعد تحرش في الجو والبحر الفين تكون يندد
بتصرفات الصين الخطره وبكى تحذر من مواجهه
كارثيه
مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
متابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات